non-minimalists
alicia writes in i've changed to a job
that makes me a lot happier but a lot
less pay
my family has had to make changes
because of it what are some changes one
can make
to make a change like this more
sustainable it's a lot of change
put that change in a jar well
here here's i'll give you the pithy
answer and then we'll talk about it a
little bit because
this is the biggest change i had to make
in my own life and i talked about it in
everything that remains
um so my pithy answer is debt free
is the new pay raise amen and that's the
one thing to think about like
if you have all of these debts if you
have student loan debt if you have car
debt you know you got this car payment
every month
you're paying for this oversized house
maybe it's a mortgage maybe it's just a
luxury condo or whatever
you're paying a big payment over there
maybe you're paying for the credit card
debt that you have
or you're paying for you know the the
the uh
all these other um bills that we have
right
debt payments yes they are just debt
payments but debt free is the new pay
raise because if you get rid of that
debt you've automatically given yourself
a pay raise so uh if you don't owe
anybody
anything then you give yourself the
freedom
to do anything yeah you can tweet that
too sean
it's funny because like i i don't get it
as often
but i used to get it a lot when we first
started the minimalist people would be
like oh well it's easy for you
because you know you walked away from
the corporate world and you obviously
had you know
uh thousands and thousands of dollars
saved up
and uh you know you're single and you
know it's all these like
these assumptions excuses yeah excuses
and ultimately i would just say to those
people like no no
it's easy for me because i spend less
money than what i make and it's not it's
not about having
thousands and thousands of dollars saved
up certainly it's it's it's it is a
great idea to have a safety net and to
save for retirement i'm not trying to
say that those things are important
but what i'm saying is is ultimately if
you want to
uh have the freedom if you want to be
financially secure you have got to start
spending less money than what you make
today
it's okay to sacrifice your comfort
as long as you're not sacrificing your
values yes and i think that's one of the
things we're spending money on all these
like creature comforts
and and we're actually stepping all over
our values and doing things that don't
align with the person we want to become
and by the way bravo to alicia here
for stepping in that direction and yeah
becoming the person she wants to be
even if it means making a little bit
less money or a lot less money in the
process yeah congratulations alicia
uh my my short answer is this if we put
money
first a meaningful life becomes the
opportunity cost
so what i mean by that for for alicia is
sometimes
we might take this pay decrease so we
can live a more meaningful life
and then once we take that pay decrease
we start to feel
the the pains or the discomfort not pain
but maybe discomfort of those
those uh those comforts that maybe we
have to give up
yeah but the thing is is to
to really feel good about the decision
that alicia's made
she she has to remind herself
how she gave up that
you know piece of her salary she gave up
the comforts yeah so she could live a
more meaningful life
a comfortable life is not a meaningful
life and here's how i look at it man
like when i
so i i don't know i made 150 or 175 000
bucks that year that last
year i left um the corporate world right
did not have thousands of dollars saved
up uh
had nothing to show for the salary that
i was making for all those years
but what i'll say though is that when
the next year when i made like 27 000
bucks 28 000 bucks i forget how much it
was
i i legitimately kind of had this
conversation with myself like man like
i made so much less money this year
and i've never been happier and like i
have never i
i traveled more that year than i had
ever traveled uh thanks to
readers letting us stay on their floor
and uh you know
us sleeping in our car i mean it wasn't
like we spent you know tens of thousands
of dollars to to go on that book tour
but but i i would sit there and i i sat
there and i remember asking myself like
okay
um i made 100 and called 150 000
less or 125 000 less than the previous
year
would i pay someone a hundred and if i
had the money
if i if i could afford it would i pay
someone 125
000 to relive that year
and i absolutely would have and that's
that's what it comes down to so
alicia if you ever start to feel the
pain you've got to ask yourself like and
when i say the pain the pain of getting
rid of those comforts you got to ask
yourself and say okay if i'm
if i'm making ten thousand dollars less
a year you got to ask yourself what i
spend or would i pay someone 10 000
if it would alleviate the stress of
making that extra ten thousand dollars
if it would allow me to live a more
meaningful life with my family
the answer is usually going to be yes
yeah if the answer is no then yeah do
something
do something different um you know
minimalism isn't about deprivation it's
not about uh just living with as little
as possible it's about living
intentionally yeah and asking yourselves
questions like that are going to help
you live more intentional
alicia i'd love to send you a copy of
our book essential it's an essay
collection
with 150 essays 12 different chapters
about
12 areas of intentional living and
there's an entire chapter in here about
finances including the plan that you and
i went through to
make sure we got out of debt and more
importantly stayed all the debt once we
got there
that's that's the like the important
next step but also investing in in your
future as well
even on a a smaller or much
smaller income so i hope you enjoyed
that copy of the central sean if you
could reach out to her give her the
audiobook
the book book or the ebook whichever
she'd like